NOW U.S. TROOPS ARADG TOANTA URE
THEY ARE THEREAC MES OON AS POSL
E
STARTI I, YOCAE
THE TALIBABA IO ALHE LANERD FAS
GOVERNOT IN GR HALF
ES THE TS I
KABUL TO
YOU GOT EXCLUSIVCE
SEE?
TO GHAZNIr: THAT'S RIGHT,.
ROVINC NOW COMPLETELY
L  T
TALIBAN.
BAS E BELONGEDO THE
Y FOUND  S, WEAPONRY,UNITION.TRN
WEE THERMELA, GOT TO R IIS TIB
APPEARS TO BE WHATST'STURE NOW O
PRESENCE IF AFGHANISTAN.
THLLRAG  BASES NOW R THE CONTROE
CE OF
ANTO TROOPS IN
T
ST GHOSTLIKET THEIR MEMORIES
T SOGE TSEE THIS, YOU KNOW
N GRANTE
CNN ALONG WITH AWARD-WINNING
KEEN OFF TPOS OFWAR.T ARRIVING
ANOTHER U.S. BASE.
AND ALREADY I CAA LARGNUMBERF MR
>> TnsHE AMERICAE HERER TATHE SE
E ATTACKEDS BASE
THD THEIR E USING
EA
ON GROUND.
STRIPPED DOWN ANSOLDWALKING RO
TO YOURSELF, WHAIT A
FOR?
AMERICA'S GREAPEH
NATIG NOW DUST.>>R BELIEF
THAT ONE DAY THEY WILL HAVY ANCT
ALLD.
OTHU
T WILL COME ON
NOT E AY Repor I ADMISSION FRO
CONTINUING A BLOODY OFFENSIVE.ST
ATE  THE BACK
OF AMERICAN CK
AT, IT'SILAR   FTHE FL
ND  OLIBAN ISOI
RE-ESTABLISH THE VER
E TO
BU INSISTSHE
P S CHANGED SINCE THENranslator
BETWEEN THAT
TAN T TH
2001 WERE NEW.
D NOW THIS TALIBAN IPERIENCED,
R ACTIVITIES ARE GOING WELL.
WE ARE OBEYING OUR LEADERS.PE A
S POAGAIN, WOMEN
RIGHILL MOVE.
WOMEN'S RIGHTSIL
PROTECTED?E ASSURE THIS TO OR T
AFGHANISTAN.
VEN RIGHTS T
EV EQUALLY.
WOHAVE THEIRWN RIGHTS.
CH ISLAS GIVEN
WOMEN, WE WILL GIVE THEM THAT
r: THAT IS CLEARLY
OPEN
NEXT TO TH A GIRLS
R TEACR SALL RELIGTTEND REGULAR
AT NIG ID Y MALE COLLEAGUES AND.
TKIN IN THIS ROOM I
PROMISED THAT ULW
THEIRES.
GIRLS WO GOING I WAT,  ANY OF T
SAYS IS BAD.HOOLD AID T RLSCHOOI
HERE, WHAT THES
GOES.
THIS IS NOW AT  LOOKSIKOMHAT THC
VI
GHS D OFS TH
SHN S CTORY.
AND, PAMELA, WE ACTULY
OFS S YOU VE
L  T
WITH THE SOLDIERS.
WE OF THEM
TOSSIONS.ES IT FEEL TO KNOW THA
TIME ON, THAT YOU WEREIG
UNDER THE CONTROOF THEON N
TALIBAN, AND ONES
NO LONGER INARS  T
START OUT RM
YORES E VE
SITUATIO'S I SEE THESE IMAAT YO
BASE, I DON' A
FEEL JUSTA  N INBELIEVABLE WASS